testing your blood sugar levels can be
daunting enough to say nothing for
actually keeping track of them over time
that's where the smart glucometer from
eye health comes in it's a little dongle
they snap onto the bottom of any of your
iOS devices and it works by taking one
of I health test strips which actually
come in their own personalized container
which has QR code to let you know it's
freshness you put a blood sample on that
you pop the strip into the bottom of the
dongle and using the glucometer app it
instantly tells your blood sugar levels
and it will keep track of them for you
over time so you can see how your blood
sugar levels fluctuate there's also a
handy FAQ for diabetes related
information it's just a really cool
at-home device for people that are
diabetic that want to keep track of
their health in a more tech-savvy way
the device is not on the market yet it's
still pending FDA approval but fingers
crossed it should be out sometimes
second half of this year